take a look at the numbers for jordan
lyles obviously numbers that he can't
improve on
although he's got a pretty good
strikeout to walk ratio
oh yeah it's a line drive into left
field so he starts
a new hitting streak and the royals have
their lead off man on just like that
first pitch look at him up 92. knew it
was coming seize it middle perfect swing
no sinker to that [ __ ] and with two on
and two outs no score in the first
inning so gets jorge solaire to the
plate 20th pitch of the inning for him
and this one is lined out to left field
but martin was right there hartley had
to move and the inning is done that ball
was smoked but for a hard out and here's
brady singer who made his first start of
the season against the rangers back at
kauffman stadium
it's a tapper back to the mound and
throws wildly to first and kinder
philippa is on it was a tough play
did a great job to get to the ball and
then felt like he had to rush it a
little bit and that cost him throws the
ball right here
and threw a sinker and bounced out in
front of the first baseman first baseman
ryan o'hearn couldn't pick it
i think if he got his feet underneath
him and took his time it would have been
a little bit closer play
runner going and this one lined out to
right field long run out there and he
can't get to it so there's going to have
to take it off the fence keiner falefa
waved around third he'll score garcia
dives into third base rbi triple and the
rangers have the first run of the ball
game
adoles slices it to right field on a
line solar couldn't quite get to it not
for a minute like he might have a chance
to get to it but it went away from him
kicked off the wall as soon as it kicked
off the wall by him it was going to be a
triple and the rangers capitalize on the
error that singer himself made on a
little tapper back to the mound now
gallow and a third and gallow lifts this
one out to left field that's carrying a
little bit dozier's back to the wall
done
an opposite field home run for gallow
look like a backup slider right down the
middle of the plate
and joey hit him well enough now jason
martin just back up with the team today
2-2 pitch and it is a fastball in there
for strike three so martin is the first
out and that's the first struck out for
brady in the inning and his second for
the ball game
this one bounced left side of the
infield and scooped by gutierrez to
second on to first but not in time
isaiah always hustling gets down the
line in time to beat that one out he's
safe field via the fielder's choice kind
of an awkward throw
for gutierrez
so he does it underhand but he does it
really well merrifield turns it really
well but isaiah runs to go for that
back-to-back singles salvador perez
pitch
this one back toward the mound
backhanded by lyles checks a couple of
bases eventually just goes to first to
get parents and he made a good choice
he might have had a chance at second but
if you throw it to second and you don't
get him
now you're in a pretty good jam flair is
up number one and here comes hunter
dozier
two two pitch now to dozier look good
strike three called
and that's twice today that dozier has
gone down looking and both times on
basically unhittable strike gerard dyson
swinging a miss here by dyson on a curve
ball and it's a one two three four eli
white is just one for 11 in this series
and now two outs that is his third
strikeout slider chase it there you go
that's a way to get him out of the zone
there he wanted to and the pitch
and a swing and a miss and he strikes
out at a fastball up those havamon first
and third with nobody out
and a line drive to center field that's
going to be down and the royals are on
the board
and whit is three for three gutierrez
comes down from third
and it is 3-1 in the fifth inning
so here's izzy he's reached on an error
to start the ranger first
kind of falafel bounces it third
gutierrez to second for one on to first
not in time again
almost the exact same play as far as
first pace goes just barely beat it two
times in a row
[Applause]
little bloop out of the left field that
drops in base hit and hustling for third
base kinder philetha got a great read on
that one at second base and decided to
go for it and he's in safely on the low
single there's some good base running so
now a little meaning on the mound
[Applause]
fastball strikes out garcia
and that's number five for brady singer
like how he just went after garcia there
blue kc pitch track shows you here it is
joey gallo on with the no pitch
intentional walk and go after andy
ibanez singers 1-0 is swung on hit on
the ground lopez grabs it goes to second
they get the force and an excellent job
by brady singer to get out of trouble
now the rangers have runners at second
and third base isaiah connor for
leftover with a chance to add to this
three-to-one rangers lead point for some
extra runs
the chopper third base side backing up
gutierrez and he bobbles a run is in
wow he's had a little trouble over there
today rangers
take yet another run
took a high hop he
waited back on the hop instead of
charging it bottom of the seventh inning
and scott barlow is the new pitcher for
the royals and he'll face nate lowe
and low chases below the zone that
strikeout begins the bottom of the
seventh inning
2-2 pitch
and the breaking ball and that one
caught the inside corner to a dolly see
that locking ball it doesn't actually
break that much two away here in the
texas half of the seventh joey gallows
steps to the plate
sets kicks and fires and a swing and a
miss on the slider down and indeed
barlow strikes out the side in the
seventh we head to the eighth just in
second and one out so the tying run
comes to the plate let's see the 20th
pitch of the inning for patton and it's
a ground ball could be two counterfeit
left for the second one on the first got
him double play
a little help from the defense makes a
huge difference for patton the inning is
done heading to the ninth the rangers
hold a four to one lead ian kennedy is
on for the rangers to try to save it
dozier who's over three leads it off and
he lines this one out to right field one
pitch one out new jerrod dyson
oh and two and did he go he did dyson
strikes out swinging two away well it's
pretty sharp location with that tailing
fastball there's a good look let's see
if he goes
yep he went here's gutierrez one for
three with a single he has scored the o2
[Music]
and that is strike three called
gutierrez
down looking a seven pitch save in the
ninth for ian kennedy and that's a happy
birthday for the skipper